mmm hi everybody my name is Akeem and I
look after Google Play business
development for apps and games I'm based
in Tel Aviv and I look after our
business in Middle East and Africa
here today we have a exciting panel of a
really cool panelists from game
companies that have all had significant
launches in the last year or so and we
wanted to pick the brain a little bit
and learn from your experiences over the
over the last year on how you really
took risk off your game launches and
improved its initial performance by
really developing and at scale and then
launching once you're ready and finding
that right balance between a good launch
strategy a good production cycle we
figured that developing and launching
games today is becoming an increasingly
expensive proposition and development
cost has been skyrocketing you need to
launch with a good storyline with proven
mechanics with amazing graphics and at
the same time you need to appeal to an
audience with a shortening attention
span increased acquisition cost and and
a real high expectations for high
quality games so all in all it's
becoming much more tricky to launch a
hit and to launch a success upfront and
there is a couple of of tools and
learning so you can really leverage to
understand early where your strengths
lie and where to best process with the
game in order to ensure the best
possible success once you actually ready
for a global production launch so and
I'd love to invite our four
distinguished panelists from really cool
game companies making a diverse range of
really awesome and highly addictive
games and please join me on stage
George Abramowitz he from King Yin's
Greg Germann CEO
Guga solutely chief commercial officer
Miniclip and Sergei Sergei Zaitsev
business development director play
Rick's Thanks we're under our protest
and we makes it alright you can guess
which one is which one is which awesome
thank you so much guys for joining
really excited to have you
stage and just an FYI I have a couple of
questions prepared but please don't
hesitate we have a couple of minutes at
the end if there's any audience
questions just feel free to you know
shout out or raise your hand we'll try
to accommodate as many as we can and
we'll have a break later on during which
you can pick this gentleman's brain as
well sorry guys if I kind of scheduled
your breaks now already awesome and
second let's start with you all the way
to the end
how you doing well good all good all
good
nice for hosting us here thanks we got a
lot to tell you you've had a massive hit
last year with garden escapes and had
now create a pretty cool follow on hit
which seems to be breaking the banks and
and reaching quite a lot of audiences
with home escapes so I wanted to ask
very specifically how and when did you
make that decision to move over and to
fork off some of your team's resources
to start developing a new title and how
did you split the resources between
continuing to develop for for garden
escapes while also developing home
escapes mm-hmm thank you for your
question so clerics has a long history
and it was very successful in DC
downloadable games and we had garden
scapes and the spin-off which was around
renovating the house it was called
mansion makeover so the spin-off in PC
downloadable world was even more
successful than the story about the
garden so it was pretty logical for us
to continue the story and build the game
around when we saw the success of Dan
escapes it was very logical for us to to
build a game around around renovating a
house so so we were pretty sure that the
concept will work so that's why we made
the decision and talking about resources
the interesting thing that we didn't
remove anyone from garden escapes to
home escapes and we collected the team
behind home escapes from scratch so we
were developing the game for one and a
half year
and initially it was ten people just
from scratch and then they came rapidly
grew to more than 60 people and right
now it's growing even more so yeah so we
didn't move any resources and we just
seek for top talent and we have the
knowledge and we had very good
experience with garden scapes and when
we when we were making home scapes we we
tried to make a game which is which is
not kind of a sequel but we wanted to
create a game which was interesting to
play in parallel with Geron scapes so we
wanted to do to change some mechanics
but we wanted to do like to stay in the
same universe we wanted to expand the
franchise so yeah so essentially you
haven't really moved
anybody from one title to the other in
terms of resourcing you really have kind
of staffed an entirely new team yes of
course there was a lot of share and
knowledge from gardenscape steam with
home scape steam but in terms of
resources we didn't move like artists
game designers and a lot of guys really
cool are these two teams competing now
internally as well I would call it like
cooperation fair sad I just wanted to
bring this up in terms of retention
we've discussed early before that
retention seems to be becoming more and
more important as a true KPI of business
success and with 8 ball pool you really
and have created the title that retains
quite some time so I wanted to ask a bit
about the secret sauce behind it and
kind of what you can share obviously in
this forum that we can learn from and
creating such a such a title that
retains for such a long time gradients
ok now we in going for 5 years now over
5 years has been out on the mobile and
it was it lived on the web as well so
much like play tricks we started our
life on the web and you know also it's
very easy for us to understand that
there would be a
towards this game seeing in terms of
retention is you know April Paul has
become pretty much almost a utility for
a lot of people you know it's it's a way
for people to play a competitive game on
mobile and you know sometimes the
traditional retention for us is that a
hundred percent always gonna be worried
about too much because actually the way
that our they've got four or two and
they haven't played the game but then
eventually come back again and then full
kins yeah just a second can everybody
hear us okay there's a lot of there was
some no okay got it
it was genius stuff guys added like five
points when you're d30 retention it's
it's unfortunate for the front row very
cool so we try to kind of reiterate some
of the some of the points that that
we're kind of lost in translation here
but maybe you would like to read through
it notes are just to repeat just to
highlight so basically just to repeat
from a high level perspective you know
we look at retention but obviously you
know April pool have living so long on
many people's devices you know the way
we reengage players and and you know
really we feel like it's more of a
utility now for people you know they
come back and they play this even if
they may have lapped for two or three
months they they will come back and then
play it for a you know kind of the
regular session kind of lanes that we
would expect to see when they first
started so we we really spend a lot of
time on on on that aspect of our of our
launch strategy and our you know
relaunching games sometimes as well
running eight ball as a utility it's
there everybody plays ball right I know
I do I can't judge from everybody else
but I'm hooked
and I have been for quite some time so
it's yeah pretty tricky to get off yes
you've just launched a turns journey and
with a really massive launch and
congratulations on this first day yeah
it looks really amazing and when we
talked you mentioned that you've you
kind of created a really long production
cycle with a pretty long roadmap of
content updates live ops and activities
that you're doing in order to reduce the
original risk at launch I wanted to to
ask a little bit about that yeah yes
so June's journeys our latest hidden
object game and came out two weeks ago
and there was really two phases during
the soft launch the first phase was okay
does this have the retention metrics
that we need to have a successful game
long-term that was something we looked
at between January and April and because
we had a previous hidden object game
before that was a big success we could
compare apples to apples and we saw very
early okay this will work right
retention is good but then we had
another six months period from from
April to October where it was really
about de-risking the launch because life
operations and content are so critical
so it's our highest production value a
game ever it's our biggest content
effort game ever it's it's pretty
ridiculous so we release a new chapter
every every single week every Friday and
every chapter is 1600 man-hours of work
so every Friday there's basically a
chapter that would take 40 people or 40
hours a week to produce every single
Friday
and with people internally without
sourcing and and that's I mean it's
ridiculous but we think it will work the
first two weeks of data indicate that
this will work our previous
hidden-object game indicates that that
will work and we really needed the
preparation time because we have an
author author team like a writing team
of three authors they write about a year
in advance so they are currently writing
the story that will appear in the game
in one year next October
there's graphic production in between
etc so what we really did is we went to
the UK and we did something we called
dress rehearsal so we we pretend that we
were live so we had weekly content
releases we had our weekly reviews on
marketing spend with it so
for media customer care we did
everything as if we were live globally
just limited to the UK across all
platforms and we didn't do that to
evaluate if the game would work from a
retention perspective we had already
done that before but to practice if we
could run life operations if we could
run counter production if we could run
localization and all of those things and
yeah that was really really key but it's
a huge bet it seems to pay off but I had
some sleepless nights I can imagine so
at what stage then during that dress
rehearsal did you make that go or no-go
decision was that like a set threshold
that you have sent or was it mostly so
so yeah we already made the we will
launch decision in April and in April we
said we will launch on October 5th so
half a year in advance we set a specific
launch date and we work backwards from
that and we would have only diverted
from this if we would have seen
something unexpected so we really used
that half year to see is there something
unexpected coming and to have those
dozens of people who are involved to
basically prepare them and train them
and get them into them into the rhythm
of what it means to run a game with life
operations and content because that's I
mean the five years after launch are so
much more important now than the two
years before yeah and that's that's what
we basically prepared for in the last
half-year
that's a new opt-in optimized during
that period for for long term retention
we optimized for long term retention so
I mean one one sentence I I say is okay
you will lose a certain amount of people
during the first week they may not like
theme they may look like the Jorah
but those who are still with you after
week you really want to keep in the long
run you really still want to have them
after year that was the mindset on
counter production so from day seven to
day 28 retention you expect a minimal
drop-off in order to justify and
actually with our hidden object games
we've now changed our reporting system
to measure day 720 retention because
these games are really about a 720 yes
two year retention so we measure two
year retention for cohorts because
long-term retention is everything for
these games that's a good segue action
to move on to George you've been running
your hit games also for the last couple
years with King running the the now very
famous candy crush and saga and the
hotel franchise and so at at figure
you'd also optimize for the long-term
retention oh yeah and I'm wondering how
you guys make the decision between
launching a new franchise to launching a
Content update on one of your existing
titles okay and basically we had to
rethink this strategy around a few years
ago when we realized that candy crush is
here to stay for a long time and we
decided to go to parallel tracks and one
is keep working on candy crush and
improve the game and keep it fresh we
are adding new life of upsetting big
extensions new content every second week
and then we also say okay we need to
also do something else right so you kind
of follow these same these two tracks
investing in existing games and also
working on launching new ones like can
be sister titles or can be sequels to
the original one but also new IDs as
well and when you do launch a sequel do
you prefer essentially are you taking
existing game teams or existing staff
from the game teams in order to develop
that sequel or like a exergy mentioned
we actually hired a completely separate
team to continue that it's a mix we also
like we need to use the expertise for
from the people that worked on previous
games some of them already know how to
build certain stuff right and yeah they
are needed in the new team but also yeah
have new new teams as well pretty cool
yeah that's working clearly that is Bart
so yeah definitely something we can we
can learn from and back back to new ends
actually I wanted to ask specifically
and about kind of the inverse of tunes
journey of what we just discussed of an
experience you've had as developing a
game with a relatively long and
scheduled and production cycle and where
you ended up with a decision of saying
this is not worth it we should actually
roll back and change and move the
research to something else so kind of
you know decide to kill no roadmap yeah
yeah we we we we question our
productions all the time and we actually
stopped games at different stages so
just a couple of days ago we stopped the
project that was already full scale into
production
over 20 people team but it was still
over a year away from launch and we saw
too many risks and and in the end
decided okay we stopped this because of
not everything was shaping up to give a
very clear picture of this will be
awesome because just good is not enough
anymore right on this market you have to
be one of the best or maybe the best in
your drama to have a chance so that was
really based on early stage relatively
early stage and based on play tests and
and subjective evaluation but we also
stopped the project in May that was in
soft launch based on retention metrics
so we day one day three retention was
good but then day seven the drop-off of
retention was too strong and and we just
stopped that in relatively early stages
of soft launch so those were two
separate cycles if you will one a
subjects latency I wanted very
subjective play test over a year away
from launch the second one was after
after a couple of months of soft launch
based on metrics so even after the
subjective measure that we figured out
it might not you know hold up the
quality still right I don't need any
developer who says oh it's easy right I
never meet them so it's super super
tough you have to be one of the best
yeah and and therefore the bar is crazy
high and you have to be quite ruthless
yeah and only if you're completely
convinced that this will be great you
should continue and and if it's oh this
is pretty good that's not enough that's
that's not acceptable can I ask a
question because you guys it's probably
more relevant for the room but everyone
talks about the retention metrics what
is your bar you said you guys set a bar
what's your bar above the forty twenty
ten like what are you going out looking
at so what we do is we look at days play
so for every install how many days on
average does a person play over the year
right over the next year and and that
that number can be high because the
long-term retention is amazing or that
number can be high because everybody
plays for the first few weeks and then
drops off and there something in the
ballpark of days played of thirty to
forty is good right so you have 100
installs and
then on average they play 30 or 40 days
during the year but obviously
monetization is also important 30 to 40
sessions no no no 34 it's like separate
days and separate days obviously out of
those hundred installs most of them play
one right right because you if you have
50% day 1 retention right that's already
cutting it so yeah that's the way we
look at it now because we think numbers
like a day 30 retention needs to be
about 15 percent or they 30 rate and she
needs to be 20 percent that that's
that's it's just a number it's just one
number you use a whole yeah you know
above you is the amount of days that
people play to figure out your
calculator right okay I think a lot of
people are moving towards that yeah we
make LTV predictions basically yeah okay
I think that's what many I hope many
people doing ya know you have to predict
LTV during soft launch and see where the
ends up that actually brings up a really
good point that and specifically to you
and do recent launch of of war wings and
I've just got a little bit surprised
that if we have that we're almost
running out of time but just to quickly
cuz talk about the war wings launch
because you really have some done
something different from from your
recent launches yeah so we we went a
little bit outside of our what people
perceive as our traditional comfort zone
where we really launched a fully 3d
dogfighting game and we kind of like
yen's has talked about the dress
rehearsal in in one territory so we'd
already done the soft launch and then we
essentially focused on doing a full
almost global launch esque kind of
campaign in one territory so we did that
in the UK so we did you know you're full
you a that you would do we did TV we did
cinema we did a lot of things we worked
with the platforms who supported us on
this endeavor to try and see what that
would do and that really gave us you
know cuz soft launch can give you a
false sense of security sometimes yes I
think a lot of people in and a lot of
product managers and all the you egg
teams will almost do too well in soft
launch because they'll have targeting
the users that they really want and the
Metra
start looking good and then so you'd
wonder why they haven't scaled when you
go into global and they'll be like oh
you know you get it it's the featuring
no you get those are these casual
audiences guys I know you guys hear it
we might as well talk about it so what
why we did that is just to really get a
good sense of what that would do on a
global stage and it's been it's proven
to be successful because it it kind of
then replicated into the global launch
when we when we pushed in our line would
that work for home scape or would that
have been a good strategy for home
escapes as well like doubling down on
one country and going all-in or do you
rather go for a global launch and then
really see down the line where you need
to focus
it's a good question so we think that
the definition for soft launch should be
different depending on the context so if
you go to the very competitive crowded
space like merge three general then I
should you should release on the
software a very highly polished and
highly polished product which is which
is pretty ready for for the commercial
launch because if you are missing any of
the features that other competitors have
in the market then you just don't will
not make it you will not make it and on
the soft launch we don't like test any
mechanics or concepts we we already we
already sure that the game is in a good
shape but what what we're testing is
retentions monetization technical side
of that nothing crushes and there that
we also test like the difficulty curve
with there which is like general
piquillo tea so so yeah and we we soft
launch in in Canada usually and
Australia and we believe that this
metrics are pretty reliable for the
commercial launch so yeah so so the
period for which we soft launch it
depends on the game and for for garden
escapes we had we soft launch it for for
several month and home escapes we we
keep we kept it in soft ones for for one
month and yeah so cool we can't rely on
these numbers but it clearly worked I
mean all of you guys have been really
successful in launching this game
this year so we've we've taken a lot of
learnings from you guys and really want
to share as much as we can
I'm really afraid that we're running out
of time and I think I have to cut this
short although I think I could stay here
for the entire afternoon do we have time
for questions though okay cool so if
somebody here in the audience has
questions please raise your hand now
it's a good it's a good time we have a
couple more minutes okay right here
hello it's a question for audience and
sad as well you both mentioned you did a
soft launch well a real global launch in
the UK we called last rehearsal cool so
what did you learn how it needs a better
name yeah what did you call it soft
global launch is not better than
somebody in this room sorry we
interrupted you learning's did you did
you get from from that because you said
so you did the result and then he
presented with you
Saad you did all your campaigns and did
you learn anything from it did I affect
the way you run the global launch after
that yeah absolutely
and that's why you do it right so I
think some of the channels in which we
expend some marketing dollars we scaled
that back other ones we we put more into
it because you know for us it was a new
type of genre for us to enter into so we
just really wanted to make sure that you
know one did our own kind of Network
respond to that kind of game what kind
of ua channels you know it does brand
marketing campaigns work for this and
that's what we got from that and you
know we took that data back and then we
rearranged what we did for global launch
yeah and and we wouldn't have got that
had we not done that kind of process so
I agree to what you said for us it was
also in addition to this because it was
our next big hidden-object game and
we've got an extremely loyal fan base we
would not we would new our best users
our VIPs from our previous hidden object
game would play Jun's journey on day one
they need to have a great experience and
therefore things like this weekly
content production which is crazy
refry they releasing a new chapter we
wanted to have practice on that and we
wanted to have practice in a in a real
market with real users and with real
customer care and with real social media
interaction and with real weekly
pressure basically on the team - yes
this has to be out to see if it really
really works or if we would break
everything when we go global so that in
addition to what you said on the
marketing side was important to us and
the other thing we learned was you know
we launched a game which is probably
sacrilege to say in here but the initial
binary download was 1.6 gigabytes so we
needed to make sure that we could do
that globally and in the UK at work so
that was a big thing for us to test as
well nice and we have time for one more
quick question first-come first-serve
all right so let me summarize with one
quick question of my own the last one
just a flash question if there is one
thing that you would want to this room
to take away like what's the one KPI or
the one - that the audience needs to or
should be should be considering when
launching a new title what's that key
KPI you're looking at George for us
always has been and always will be
engagement and as well as retention
right so understand why players play
your game why players don't like your
game and that's that's key to to further
grow your game as well right you need to
know exactly what are the pain points
and yeah fix them as soon as possible
and very important for lunch I would say
it's have enough content for the most
engage players like like you're saying
as well I mean don't underestimate that
and you know just make sure that there's
enough content for the most engage
players out there right it can be very
vocal afterwards if they run out of it
so yeah you don't want to get your you
know last value gamers getting
disappointed very quickly or them having
finished the gamers absolutely authoring
at the 10th you know been affected
myself also sometimes of having reached
the end of the game yeah too quickly and
in so
- what you said George on retention
during soft launch I think it's really
when you're a super early stage or early
stage and you're doing your your
playtesting see excitement if you don't
see excitement among your team among
people who play it very bad sign that's
a good cue third for us long term
attention is probably the most important
thing for us to look at and for I think
the one issue that I think we discussed
this in this industry it's funny because
you know 15% B 30s that would be very
good right or 10% B 30 would be good but
that's kind of crazy if you think about
it your game started with 100 users and
now you've got 10 again as a as an
industry and as a you know as game
makers and it's content developers we're
going to need to improve that I think in
the future
it ought to be very difficult to kind of
have viable businesses if we keep going
down that route I agree yeah if it was
only one advice I'd suggest to focus so
what like focus a lot on the product and
focus only on critical things like when
you're soft launch a game there should
be only a small list of most critical
things that you should focus on you
should not you should ruthlessly drop
everything not important and focus only
on important things if it all and what's
important is always dependent on the
game on the context like if if you have
a game but I don't with them amazing
graphics and the graphics is the most
important feature so you should make
sure that this is core and you should
polish it a lot and you should care less
about leagues or clans for for a game
but if it's a pvp pvp game then you
should make sure that pvp is pretty
polished and graphics is less important
and yeah so and this is play decks way
we focus a lot we don't do many games
and it for us it is also good results so
I advise you to try it - maybe so
content focus retention that's
essentially that the key the key summary
points to them that I'm getting
here gentlemen thank you so much for
coming up on stage and for agreeing to
share and with the wider team I invite
you all to to come and find and find our
panelists afterwards at the break if you
want to pick their brain and get some
more specific specific advice and I wish
you a very successful and invaluable
rest of the day thank you very much
[Applause]
you